autre sujet le secrétaire d'état chargé
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
thierry mandon était cet après midi à
saint quentin en yvelines il a visité
les installations équipements rénovés de
challenger l'occasion de présenter des
projets innovants au service de la
pédagogie et de qualité de vie dans le
campus de demain écouter le les têtes au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
parce que notre système d'université à
deux mutations énorme à conduire
premièrement on doit révolutionner la
façon d'apprendre la pédagogie ça passe
par le numérique est ici dans le campus
connectés dans le savoir-faire du campus
connectés de bruit il ya ces
technologies là qui sont domestiqués
deuxièmement nous avons en termes de
stratégie immobilière de faire des
locaux à la fois confortables
accueillant hospitalier une nouvelle
façon d'apprendre et en même temps
respectueux de l'environnement aussi un
autre défi et je trouve qu'il ya pas de
visite plus approprié que celle ci pour
voir des expériences concrètes de
réussite de la transformation numérique
de la pédagogie et de la transformation
durable de l'immobilier